Hi.
I'm Mano Marks.
I'm coming to you from the
Googleplex in Mountain View,
California.
I'm on the Maps Developer
Relations Team, and this is a
new Google Maps shortcut on
using tile layers in the
Google Maps SDK for iOS.
So what is a tile layer?
A tile layer is you providing
to the map a layer of raster
images in a pre-defined URL
scheme that you give to us,
and then we render those tiles
on top of our map in the SDK.
So let's take a look
at a demo for you.
This demo actually comes with
the Google Maps SDK.
So if you download the SDK,
you'll see that it's in there.
You add your own key, and then
you'll be able to run a
variety of different samples.
This one is a tile layer that
we generated for the 2010, I
believe it was, Google I/O
showing the Moscone Center
different floors.
So you'll see here we have a
little controller which I can
switch between, and we'll
see different maps.
And you can even, if you watch
closely enough, see that you
can see some of the tile
boundaries until I've loaded
it enough times that that
doesn't show up.
So what I'd like to do is show
you how to actually put this
code on your own application.
So let's take a look at
the sample code here.
I'm not going to go through
all the constructing a map
stuff because we've done
that many times.
But let's just take a look at
this ChangeSwitcher here.
So you'll see here there's a
GMSTileURLConstructor urls.
Basically it's a quick method
to show how to construct a
tile URL based on
your own tiles.
So you see here you're passing
it at an x, a y, and a zoom.
And these are the dimensions
of your tiles.
So the base URL here is here.
We're just showing you a URL
that we actually have at
Google, tiles, and then you'll
see here this is a
stringWithFormat there.
It takes floor, zoom,
x, and y.
So floor is the floor that
you've selected.
So you can see you can construct
your own URL here,
not just with the
x, y, and zoom.
And then you create a new
GMSURLTileLayer and construct
it with a tileLayerWithURL
Constructor:urls.
And then you set the map on
that to your map view.
So it's pretty easy to do once
you've constructed your own
URL scheme.
And you can use the same URL
scheme, the same formats, as
you would use for an Android or
web application that would
also be using a tile layer
or a tile overlay.
We've also added the ability to
do customization for this.
So you can actually generate
these tiles from URLs within
your application or actually
generate custom
images on the fly.
So let's take a look here.
I'm just going to show
you some of the
basic code for that.
Here we're subclassing
GMSSyncTileLayer.
So that's the header.
And then this is the
implementation.
This is just code that's in
the documentation itself.
So you see here in the
implementation, we are
changing tile for
x, y, and zoom.
And here, for every odd tile,
we're rendering an image and
pulling up an image from the
resources named australia.
So basically, it's just
rendering a map of Australia
every other tile and then not
rendering one otherwise.
So you can see here, there's
the constant
GMSTileLayerNoTile.
So let's take a look at the
demo again here, now that
you've seen the code.
So you see here, as we're
selecting the floor, it's
passing, it's changing the URL
for the layer, setting the
original layer to nil, and then
rendering new tiles on
top of the map based
on that URL scheme.
So that's it.
It's actually a pretty
simple process.
And this allows you to generate
your own imagery and
map tiles and then render
them on top of our map.
So that's all for this week.
Thanks very much, and
happy mapping.